let's pawn mate i think that was the
next challenge
where do i go three minutes
oh it's hard in three minutes especially
against a good player
i'll try
debating what opening to play
french no let's play i just have to play
quickly and preserve time
okay we're gonna have one of these i'm
just gonna play my main wrapper tour
so the first step is not to lose second
step is mate with a pawn
g3
i think a6 is a move
this is a weird move but it's playable
because i played i i stopped like b5
so e5 might be possible but then i maybe
could take it i don't know
takes
maybe
okay i'm liking the position
wow that's playable
i don't feel too too much in danger
i'm still up a pawn too
nice diagonal for the bishop
so the goal essentially is to get some
end game where like i'll eventually
mate with i guess my king side pawns
that's a tricky move
95 is interesting
so light squares are a little bit weak
my bishop's pinned though
in queen h5 i have you just have this
[Music]
move
i guess this means i can't dirty flag
oh stoned eagle says i can do one more
but which challenge
always down for bounty challenges i
haven't lost too much rating
like games i lost i was playing good
players anyway
gwaki go blind not right now
wait what free peace
what is this
what was that move i just sacked a piece
rook takes was tempting because not f3
but okay here i'm just a material
i guess rookie seven is idea like queen
d6
queen f6 comment
so i'm pretty sure there's a thing like
i'll go blind in casual games only
maybe i'll go blind between games
but this is this is like a serious
situation right now
because how do i mate with a pawn maybe
the g pawn eventually
opponent might resign though that would
be sad
so i basically have to drag the king up
the board
and then mate it
okay maybe i can take my time here and
figure this out
don't resign don't flag
i'm so disappointed oh it's not over yet
i'm thinking like my best hope to mate
with a pawn is some crazy time scramble
so maybe i'll get very low on time
intentionally kind of i'm still gonna
i'm gonna win
but um
how do i do this to force a king
maybe like this
okay interesting
okay maybe this pawn will be the miracle
worker
oh wow that was a good move if i take i
get mated
very sneaky i have to take the bishop
[Music]
don't resign don't resign don't flag
more time
um i have to move
i forgot i can give my opponent more
time
ah
let's go let's go i got the pond mate
i got the pawn mates with four seconds
left
oh it's upon me
wow that's not easy
because you have to find a balance
between like just crushing the opponent
but giving them a little bit of hope
and a little bit of more time
okay
thank you vtg i appreciate it nice
uh that was a risky decision because i
could have flagged
but
legend and then the king so the problem
was the king wasn't
within like mating distance of the pawns
so i basically had to
not push the pawns to prompt the king to
move back
pornmate everyone pay up oh
thanks for that thanks called the kid
thank you and
kid durino and g
cook i appreciate that i worked so hard
yeah hi youtube yeah do i put this on
youtube
trying to pawn me for money
thanks people thanks soy sauce good
stuff